Okay.
So we're talking about Nmr spectroscopy
and today we'll talk about that.
Tools that you use to identify are the
aspects of Nmr Nmr spectroscopy that
allow you to assign
structures to molecules. Uh,
so the chemical shift, which
involves diamagnetic, anti Satrapi,
the word that you will impress your
friends with and spin, spin coupling.
And maybe at the end we'll get
to dynamics if not next time.
So as we said last time there,
the,
the precession frequency of
the protons in a molecule,
a depends on the magnetic field they see,
which is mostly this enormous
applied magnetic field.
But there's also a little fields in the
molecule that make a difference to give
this effective field in particular,
the orbiting of electrons,
the net orbiting of electrons,
because they orbit both
ways and mostly cancel.
But a little bit of net orbiting gives
rise to what's called the chemical shift,
which can change the field by 12 parts
per million in roughly for protons,
sometimes a little more 200 parts per
million for carbon because they're more
electrons around carbon. Right?
But there's another effect,
another magnet to bear in mind that
the magnetic aspect of nuclei is not
influenced by electric
stuff, right? So that that a,
a proton,
the nucleus of a in a molecule
is held in position in x,
Y, z by the electron
density around it. Okay?
That's the bonds we talk about.
But the orientation of the magnet,
right, is not, is not at all
or is rarely effected by that,
right? It's affected only by magnetic
things, not by electric charges.
Okay.
Just moving electric charges that generate
magnetism does it so that it's as if
the, the Proton is on
a, is on a perfect, uh,
uh, ball bearing or something. If this
is the molecule and the Ma and the,
and the molecule rotates the,
the,
the spin keeps pointing to the same way,
right?
It doesn't rotate with the molecule.
Okay.
We'll talk about that a little
more on just a second. Uh,
okay. But, but so the things that are
magnetic or the circulation of electrons
and nearby magnetic nuclei,
they're obviously magnetic too.
So if there's more than one magnetic
nucleus, then you get what's called spins.
Been splitting as we'll discuss and
notice that the units are different from
that. We talk about the units of spins,
been splitting in terms of hurts.
That is frequency, that is
energy, not parts per million,
not a fractional unit. And you'll
see why. So first the chemical shift,
which is due to this electron orbiting
and involves diamagnetic can I Satrapi.
Hey, we saw last time this idea
that when you have higher, uh,
electron density around the Proton,
you get more of this diamagnetic
shielding and the peaks are shifted to the
right.
And when you have less electron density
is in the carboxylic acid there shifted
to the left.
And that made some sense.
But there were things
that didn't make sense,
like a settling where you'd think that
the sp hybridization of the carbon would
withdraw electrons from the hydrogens
and shifted down field compared to the
double bond. It shifts it up field.
Right? And furthermore, as you'll see,
the same thing applies to benzene.
It's shifted downfield compared
to other hydrogens on carbon,
carbon double bonds.
And the reason is this thing
called diamagnetic anti Satrapi,
which we will now discuss.
So you get Daya magnetism from orbiting
electrons. So suppose that, uh,
that red.is the nucleus and we're in an
applied field and there are electrons
that are circulating around the nucleus
and they create the name Daya magnetism
means that opposes the applied field.
So they reduce the field that seen by the,
by the nucleus.
And that's the source of these splittings.
We were these shifts that
we were talking about. Okay,
but now we're talking here about
electrons orbiting around this nucleus.
The one we're looking at,
there are lots of other electrons in
the molecule orbiting other nuclei.
What effect do they have?
Okay,
so suppose we're interested in
the field at the red nucleus,
but there's some other nucleus,
the blue one and electrons are
circulating around it too. Now,
what effect is that going to have on the
field seeing at the red nucleus? Okay,
well we can look at the lines of force
and see it has the same kind of effect
but not as strong because it
depends on one over r cubed.
So as you move away,
the effect gets smaller.
That's not surprising that you can see
the lines of force get further away as
you move further up,
okay?
So the effect is weaker from the same
number of orbiting electrons on another
nucleus.
That's fine.
But suppose that the nucleus were studied
is fixed relative to the other nuclei
by bonds buy a bond like
that or other bonds.
It could be connected in a complicated
way to the blue nucleus, okay?
And suppose that the molecule rotates,
right? So it's not always in the same
field. So we can look at it like this.
Here's the, uh, can you see
this here? Okay, so here's the,
here's the nucleus we're interested in,
and here's the other nucleus about which
things are spinning or are orbiting,
right? And as we go like this, right?
Sometimes we're in a region
where the field is pointing up,
sometimes in a region pointing down.
In fact,
I have it the wrong way here because
I'm wanting to use this same diagram for
another purpose later,
okay? But you can see that,
that we're going to have to average,
if the molecule is tumbling rapidly to
see what the influence of electrons here
are when we're over here.
Okay.
So let's try to do the average.
Okay. When it was up, when it was,
when the bond was pointing up, we saw that
the field pointed down. How about here?
When the bond is down, which way does the
field point from the blue circulation?
Debbie,
look at the lines of force. Which way
are they pointing down road? Where?
Where the red nucleuses down.
Okay. So it's the same. Good.
That's going to reinforce it. But
suppose it's turned at 90 degrees there.
Keep us going, Debbie. Now, which
direction to those lines points.
Oh, okay. And how about if
we rotate to the other side?
And how about a four at 45,
or actually some a little bit
less than 45 degrees there.
Oh, they're pointing sort of down
to the, uh, down to the right. Okay.
And if we're over there,
they're pointed down to the
left and if they're down here,
down at the bottom there,
pointing down to the right or the left,
depending on where we are.
So we have to average all of these.
Some of them are bigger than others. There
are pointing in different directions.
But notice that if we average
over a whole circle of rotation,
then the ones that are at
the top and at the bottom,
within the scope of those
double headed yellow arrows,
those are all net down,
right?
Some are down very strongly,
some are down very weakly and the right
and the left one's cancel one another,
right? And the right to left.
So it's net down at the top,
net down at the bottom also.
But on the sides it's net up.
Everybody with me now
which one's gonna win?
Yeah,
the ups and the downs.
Why do you say the downs first?
They're more of them,
right? And second, they
can be stronger. In fact,
if this turns out up at the top to be
twice the lines of force are twice as
close together here as they are out here,
there's a factor of two.
So clearly the downs have it right.
So if you average around the circle,
you're going to get net down. However,
that's not the way you average.
Can everybody see why you
don't average around a circle?
When I look at the effect of this,
the fields over here on this,
why don't I just average around a circle?
Because the molecule is not held
in a plane. It can go this way too.
Okay? So we have to average over
a sphere, not around a circle,
right? And notice that when
you average over a sphere,
you get much more area around the
equator than you do up at the polls going
around the sphere.
So now that's going to be an advantage
for the ones that are pointing up a much
heavier weight and the averaging,
right?
And it turns out that the net
average over a sphere is zero.
And that's great because it means you
don't have to worry about it, right?
You can't get an effect from someplace,
the circulation someplace else.
If you're only interested in the
ones that are circulating about you.
Right.
That obviously simplifies our life greatly
except for diamagnetic anti Satrapi.
Okay, so let's see what that is. So we
can ignore the electrons on other atoms.
Good News.
Unless orbit,
unless the amount of orbiting depends
on the orientation of the molecule and
then they aren't all that or not.
That's not always the same orbiting
for different orientations. Okay,
so let's just suppose that were up
there and suppose when the molecule is
oriented vertically,
that way when our nucleus is above
these circulating the electrons,
suppose there's less orbiting for
some reason in that orientation.
So we're going to make that a pink things
thinner and that will have the effect
of making the magnetic field less.
The lines of forests are now further apart
and that means we don't have as big a
field up on the up on top.
Everybody see?
So if it Everage to zero
before it will average up.
Now everybody with me because we've cut
down on the amounts that are going up.
When the molecule is in this orientation,
if when it's down in
the other orientation,
you have the full compliment of
circulation, then the DA, then the,
the ups are going to win. Okay, so that,
and this is what's called diamagnetic
and I saw atrophy diamagnetic as this
circulation that causes a field opposed
to the applied field and is driven by
the applied field.
Right.
The reason it's there is because you
put the applied field on and if you put
more applied field on you get
more of it. But in a, in a stay,
in a fixed field, right? You
have this diode magnetism,
but it's not isotropic isotropic means
the same in all directions if it's
different in different directions
than it doesn't cancel anymore.
So diamagnetic anisotropy
means that you're in trouble,
that you have to consider the
electrons on other nuclei as well.
So let's consider that
in the case of benzene.
So we have these Pi orbitals
overlapping in benzene.
And then when you put a magnetic
field on in that direction,
you can cause circulation of those
electrons. Net circulation. Okay.
Now that creates the field that's,
that's opposed to the applied
field in the middle of the ring.
But reinforcing the applied field
out on the, where the protons are.
Everybody with me on that.
So it's reinforcing the
applied field however.
So it's like that.
But if you turn the molecule edge edge on,
then you don't have the path anymore
where they can circulate because they're
driven by the big field.
They circulate around the big field
and now the path isn't there to go on.
So it turns it off or at least reduces
it when you turn the molecule that way.
So this is exactly a
situation of diamagnetic anti
Satrapi where you have the
effect for some
orientations and not others.
And now there'll be a net average
field due to the circulation in these p
orbitals of carbon as
seen by the hydrogens,
which is what you're looking
at in your NMR spectroscopy.
So it's a net d shielding.
The orientation shown here is the one
that dominates, where the field is big,
where the circulation is big, it's not
big when you turn it the other way.
So this,
this one wins and this one,
notice this one reinforces the applied
field at the position of the nuclei were
interested in.
So that means that they
get shifted down field.
So that's why in benzene,
the protons are further down field that
way than you would have expected just
from their being in an sp squared bond.
Okay.
Now this then provided, once this
was appreciated, Nmr came along.
It came along at the same time that
people were interested in hookah.
Lara meticisly four n plus two and it
was a happy coincidence because in a
molecule like this one here,
which has 14 Pi electrons,
is that four n plus two right?
It's four times three plus two.
So this is like Ben should
be like benzene, right?
Four Times three plus two and this is,
this is the Nmr spectrum in the normal
region of that compound. However,
what comes at zero? Remember
what comes at zero. That's tms,
our reference peak.
And what comes at 7.2 that turns
out to be the solvent flora form,
right? So tms and chloroform, there
are no peaks for our compound,
right? The reason is we have to
look out of the normal range,
right?
So if you look for those protons,
you find them way down there further
down from where benzene usually comes,
which is in the seven to eight region.
Okay.
And that's exactly the same region that
they're out beside the plain of this
thing that Molly, the electrons
are circulating around that loop.
When the molecule is flat like this,
and it feels exactly the same kind of
effect as in benzene, except more so.
Okay. Now, but there are methyl
groups there too. Where are they?
Do we have to go still further down field?
Where are the methyl groups?
Right?
So there's a picture of the molecule
taken from an x ray crystal structure and
you see the circulation would be around
this path. Where are the methyl groups?
The methyl groups are in the middle,
right where the lines of force are going
the other direction and you find them
up here.
Right?
So that's a really dramatic example of
this diamagnetic and I Satrapi hey now,
uh, there, there, uh, once people got
this particular bit in their mouth,
they started looking a lot of other cases.
For example,
this molecule that we talked about,
which member had that ch two bridge
across the middle and then 10 Pi electrons
four times two plus two, right?
And again,
you see them shifted downfield when
they're outside and upfield when they're
inside, okay, now they're
not shifted as far.
Why not shifted as far?
There's not as much ring current.
They're not as many electrons. But the
other reason is that that was distorted.
So the overlap isn't as good and you
don't get as much circulation right?
But still you can see that it is,
uh,
it is benzine like it is in this context.
Aromatics aromatic because the
ch two is shifted up above tms.
Very unusual.
Okay.
Now that's 14 Pi electrons.
Suppose you treat it with potassium.
Potassium easily gives up electrons. It
reduces the compound. In fact, it put,
you can put two electrons into it.
And for this purpose,
we're going to condense the scale. Same
spectrum, but I just squeezed the scale.
And for reasons that will
be obvious. Okay, that,
so they're the sort of super aromatic
hydrogens shifted downfield to about nine
parts per million and the ones
on the inside shifted way up.
But if you put two more
electrons in and make the dye,
and I on like that,
now it's not aromatic anymore.
It's four n instead of foreign plus two.
And look at its Nmr spectrum.
They exactly shift, right?
So aromatic goes one way.
Hocal antiemetic goes the
other way, right? So this was,
so there were lots and lots of examples
done like this during the 1960s and
early seventies
okay.
So the ch three signal shift
downfield by 26 parts per million,
despite adding member that the electric,
they're more electrons.
Now we've put two more electrons into
the system. They should shield it,
but in fact it's de shielded by 26
parts per million. Really dramatic.
Okay, so it's an anti aromatic
dance, Diane Ion. Now,
how about a settling right now,
a settling has these p orbitals that
it's were written at vertical here.
There are two p orbitals.
And remember about when we talked
about what the electrons look like.
If you have p orbitals equally occupied,
if you have three p orbitals each with
two electrons in it and look at the total
electron density, what does it
look like? It's a sphere, right?
It's not lumpy.
And to give a cylinder,
right? So this, this thing
has a cylinder around.
It's around the carbon carbon triple bond,
right?
So there's a path in which
electrons can circulate. Okay,
so we get a this diamagnetic current,
when we put a field on
that and get these fields,
how is this different from the case
in Aram? Anticipate? Do you see
when it was benzene, it could
circulate when the molecule was flat,
right?
And the hydrogens are out here.
Now it circulates when the molecule is
oriented this way and the hydrogens are
above the middle. So the lines of force
go exactly the opposite direction.
But as in benzene,
when you turn the molecule,
you don't have the path for circulation.
So it's Daya magnetically and isotropic.
It goes one way and not the other.
This is the way that wins.
And the nuclei of acetylene lie above
the orbiting path where there is ringed
current.
So the applied field is diminished in
the signal shifts up field rather than
downfield. So that's why when you
made it sp rather than sp squared,
it didn't go downfield because
of the electro negativity.
It went up field because of diamagnetic
and I sought therapy and it's just the
opposite of what you see in Benzie
and where the protons are beside the
circulating path rather than on its axis.
But here's a warning.
This is a handy picture and has
been taught for for 50 years now,
I guess close to, uh,
but it might be nonsense.
And Professor Weiberg
has done calculations and
observations that show that it
doesn't work for c 13,
whether it works for Protons,
uh, I'm not sure, but at any rate,
it's a really handy picture to
remember who shifts which direction.
And it has sort of the
ring of truth about it,
but it might not be supported by really
careful calculations of the kind of
Professor Weinberg does. Okay. So that's,
that's the idea of
diamagnetic anti Satrapi.
And what gives rise to chemical shifts.
These things we talk about
pulling electrons away.
Mostly it's the electrons on the
nucleus in question that are important.
And as you pull the electrons
away, you get a shift, uh,
downfield right?
Apartment downfield downfield set
direction for you. Okay, good. Okay. But,
but you,
but in special circumstances you have
this diamagnetic anisotropy then you have
to think about it in the
terms we just talked about.
But there's also the local fields
that are due to other nuclei.
And this is called spin spin
splitting. For example. This is a,
this has taken,
and again,
I will recommend to you
this chem two 20 website,
which has NMR problems. They give
you a spectrum and say, what is it?
And then the nice thing is you
can show a spectrum like this.
They allow you to go in and look in
detail at the peaks and see what they're
integral is our and uh,
and,
and also gives a detailed explanation.
So there's an answer key.
So that's a handy place to go. But this
is, this is the first problem in that set.
Now you can see there are three kinds
of protons in this. It turns out,
I'll give you the answer first,
that it's ethyl acetate. Okay?
So there's,
there'll be two groups of three
protons and one group of two protons.
So obviously these are the three and
that's the two. Okay. But let's look at,
let's zoom in.
As this program allows you to do,
has that website allows you to do,
and when you look at that triplet,
you see that it's the,
when you look at that peak,
you see it's in fact three peaks and
they're in the ratio one to two to one in
their intensity.
Now why is that?
Those are the ch three
groups of the methyl group,
ch three protons of the, of
the a methyl group, right?
But adjacent to it,
there are two other protons
in the vicinity, right?
And you can have those oriented,
each of those can be oriented
either with or against the field.
So there are two of them.
Each can be with or against the field.
So there are four different ways
to do it. Okay. To to the two.
Okay.
So they're different molecules which
have different orientations of next door.
Protons. Okay. Of those protons.
Now let's think about those.
They could both be down,
they could both be against the field
and then we get this peak. Okay.
Or they could both be with the
field and then we get this peak.
Okay.
So that you have it when you think you
have just one kind of molecule there.
In fact,
you have what you might call,
nobody calls them that I
think spin isomers. Right.
They differ only in how these neighboring
protons have their spin oriented,
but they're different molecules
in there. Okay. So there,
but they are so similar and energy.
The magnetic interaction of the protons
with the field is so small and energy
that the Boltzmann constant is
one equal amounts of the two.
I mean there's a tiny,
tiny difference,
but not that you could measure
by the intensity of the lines.
So they're equally abundance.
So the yellow peak is just as
big as the peak or agreeing.
Okay.
Now what's that?
That's when one of them is up and the
other is down and it's just as likely as
the others.
So it's one to one to one,
but you can also have one
down in the other up right,
the opposite direction and that fit.
So that's why it's one to two to one
because they're all four of those are
equally likely.
And to have them come in the middle where
they cancel each other in their effect.
Okay, so that's a triplet.
Now how about this thing here?
That's a core tet and we can
figure out how that works too.
That's the Cah twos. They're shit.
Why are they shifted? Downfield
why did they come farther to the
left from where the methyl group was?
The chemical shifts there because the
oxygen's withdrawing electrons. Okay,
so are shifted down there.
They're integrates for two.
That's how many protons are
being involved. So it's that.
It's that the ch two group,
but it's a quartet. Why? Well,
let's look at the name now. There are
three hydrogens on the next door, carbon.
So they're going to be eight
different spin isomers uh, uh,
differ in the spins.
Then of the adjacent a hydrogen nuclei.
So let's think about it. There's the ones
that were, they all oppose the field.
They'll be up at the right,
the one where they're all with the field,
that'll be at the left,
and then you can have
one down or two down,
or our second one down or a third one
down. But they're all the same, right?
All have one down. So they come to that
peak and then there's one of them up,
a different one up, a different one up.
So it's one to three to three to one.
Okay. So if we have three neighbors,
we get one to three, to three to one.
If we have two neighbors,
we get one to two to one.
What if you have only one neighbor?
What patterns should you see?
Probably if he had just
won neighboring proton.
And you're looking at this one here,
what will it,
what will the signal of this when
you're looking at look like, right.
There'll be a peak like one.
Some molecules will be like that.
Others will be like that.
It'll be one to one. Okay.
So if it's just one, it'll be
one to one. Now what if it's for
anybody know what that one's going
to be? Yeah. One, four, six, four,
one. How did you get that?
Right? It's Pascal's triangle,
the binomial coefficients.
So it looks like we can do
this for anything, right?
We're in good shape. Okay.
Now, how, how big is this splitting?
It's measured in energy units in Hertz,
and that's called Jay. And
they're, they're equal.
You expect those to be equal because both
of them involve the same change in the
neighbor, right? Flipping one
proton. Okay. And at the same time,
those are all the same too.
But this is exactly what
you could say we should say,
because the influence of this magnet on
this magnet has gotta be the same as the
influence of this magnet on this magnet.
If they're the same kind of magnet,
all protons. Right? So
that's great. They're, uh,
and notice it won't depend on how big the
magnetic field is because this is just
the interaction between two magnets,
which have fixed magnitudes.
It was different for the orbiting
because the orbiting was created by the
magnetic field. When you had more magnetic
fields, you've got more orbiting, right?
So the chemical shift is
measured in fractional units.
What fraction of the big field does
it shift at? Some parts per million.
But this is measured in Hertz and
energy because it doesn't depend on the
applied field.
So it's independent of Bz zero
versus the chemical shift,
which as we know does depend on be zero.
The orbiting is driven by be zero.
Okay, now let's look at
another one. This is ethanol.
A spectrum measured over
the break by Phil for us.
Okay. Now, uh, so we had
o, h, c h two and ch three.
Uh, let's see if we can
figure out all these peaks.
Which one is that furthest to the right?
Which, which of the protons
in ethanol is that peak?
That's furthest to the right,
which turns out to be a triple
what it's on the methyl group,
cause the other ones
have oxygen withdrawing.
So it's the further it has the highest
chemical shift or the lowest number of
chemical shifts least shifted
down from zero. Right?
And it's a triplet. Is that makes sense
to you? That it should be three lines.
Okay.
What do you say?
Why?
No, th th th th it's three protons, right?
But the signal is not a single peak.
Three times as big as the others.
It's three peaks. One to two to
one. What causes that splitting?
You remember it's not chemical shift.
It's called spins. Been
splitting. What's the other spin?
That splitting years signal.
It's the protons on the adjacent carbon
and there are two of them and you can
orient it in, in uh, uh, in this, uh,
two to the three to two to the two ways.
Four ways.
One bomb bump. Okay. That's
what we just talked about.
So it's a triple if that's
what you expect. Okay,
so that's the splitting of the ch
three by the ch two protons. Okay.
Now let's look down at the other end.
And incidentally,
the chemical shift positions is
measured on the spectrometer or that,
but actually we should measure it not in
parts per million where the difference
is 0.018 parts per million.
We should measure it in Hertz.
So the,
so the Hertz units are at 7.2 hertz.
We by the frequency of the spectrometer,
which it says here is 400
megahertz. Okay? So it's 7.2 hertz.
Okay, now we looked down there and
we see a triplet. What's that do to
Alex? Yeah. Why? Why is it,
why is it the,
Ooh,
so it's got two neighbors,
right? Okay. So that's,
and it's shifted all the way down
field because of the oxygen electron
withdrawing. It would
appear. Okay, so there,
that's the ch two splitting the other
direction. Now let's compare those two.
They're not the same size.
The interaction between the Oah and the
Cah two is smaller than the interaction
between the ch three and the Cah
two. Right? That one is 5.1 hertz.
Okay.
Now what's this thing here?
What's that do to that?
So that's the ch two and what's it
split by? The age of the O, h and h is,
okay,
so how many H's all together and what
do you expect the Intensity v one four,
six, four one. So let's blow it up.
Okay. Is it a one, four, six, four,
one quintet?
Not Quite.
Now what is going on? Notice that those
two interactions are not the same,
right? One is 7.2 hertz and the others
5.1. So if we look at those there,
we see a quartet that split by how many?
That's foot by three.
That's the ch three splitting.
But in fact there are two quartets,
right? So that's the smaller
splitting Dubai to the Oah.
Now had they been the same then the
separation of the three on the sh,
the separation of the, of the
two quartets would have been, uh,
let's see.
Would it been instead of being like this,
it would be like this and then it would
be one, four, six, four, one right?
But that doesn't look like that.
It's actually what we call a doublet
of quartets or a quartet of doublets.
Okay. So that's a little
bit different. Okay.
Now there's some other tiny peaks here.
What's this one do to?
Any thoughts?
What a good idea could be water,
but it's not.
The solvent is dms o d six but unless
you would spend an absolute fortune,
you have some dms o d five
in there that has one proton,
right?
So those few molecules of the solvent
that have hydrogen on them look like that,
right? So you'll see a signal
from that, okay, that's fine.
And that's what the signal
looks like. Now, there are
no other hydrogens in there.
What's causing spins been splitting?
Deuterium is also magnetic.
It's not very strong magnet.
So it doesn't have a very big splitting.
These splittings are very small, right?
And furthermore, not only is it
a weaker magnet than a proton,
but so that it's only 1.8 hertz,
right?
It could be oriented three
ways in the field. Remember,
Proton can be with or against,
but to do tiering them can be with,
against, or across. So now there
are three ways of putting it.
So if you have two of
them with three ways,
it turns out what you get instead
is a one, two, three, two,
one quintet. And you can work
that out for yourself if you, if,
if a single would splits at one to
one to one because there are three
orientations, right? What did
to do so you can work that out.
If you figure that out, then you'll
understand the math we've been doing here.
Okay. Now here's another
peak. Matt, what's this peak?
Why did I ask you? Is that
water? That's water. Yeah. Okay,
good. Okay. But look over here
just to go to this.
What are those?
Yeah,
blow it up.
This bit here.
These little ones are due to
an artifact of the instrument.
Don't worry about those,
but these are real here and there.
So they both look like they're triplets,
right?
Like what's in the middle
of them is a triplet, right?
And there's a 7.2 7.2 hertz splitting,
which is exactly what you had here,
right?
So it looks like it's being split
by the CIA, by the ch two next door.
That's the splitting here.
We're looking at something that has to
do the ch three, it's been split by that,
but there's something else
that's splitting at what
else could be splitting it.
Okay,
there's another magnetic nucleus.
It can't be this h out here
because that's so far away.
It would have a minuscule effect.
This is an enormous effect.
This doublet splitting and the ideas,
it's sort of related to this one actually.
There's another nucleus there that's
magnetic, but only 1% of the time.
These are only half a percent
as big as this is, right?
So the total of this,
and this is just 1%,
there's 1% of some other
magnetic nucleus in their carbon.
It's carbon 13 right?
And that has an enormous
interaction with the protons.
I did a 125 hertz.
That's much closer to the protons.
Okay? That's one per one point. 1%
of carbon and natural abundance.
And notice one other thing that
we're going to address later, uh,
probably we won't get to it today, which
is that these are slightly asymmetric.
This one's just slightly
bigger than that one, right?
And the green ones here are slightly
bigger than the pink ones. Right.
And this one is slightly bigger than
that one. And we'll get to that too.
So we've looked at this
in pretty much detail now.
What determines the strength
of the spins, spins, splitting,
how many hertz it's going to be.
Uh,
and so we're going to
talk about isotropic, uh,
j coupling between protons.
Yeah.
And it's not a through
space magnetic interaction.
It's mediated by bonding electrons.
Uh,
because that's what this was
actually made for here are the,
here are the lines of force created by
this nucleus and we're looking at this
one. So it can be like this
or it can be like that. Okay.
So we get a doublet of when we're
looking at this proton over here,
because this one can be
either this way or this way,
but that if we follow it's lines of force,
they can either oppose the applied field
or they can help the applied field.
And what do we get if the molecule is
tumbling in three dimensional space for
the average of that?
Zero.
Because now you're not going
to get diamagnetic anti
Satrapi because this magnet
has nothing to do with the circulation
of electrons and where the pants are.
It's just the the nucleus itself and
they're on perfect ball bearings, right?
So there's no nos special stuff going on,
so it'll absolutely canceled to zero.
But then how in the world do we
get interaction between the two?
How do we get splitting if the through
space interaction of magnets won't do the
trick?
Yeah.
Okay. It goes through bonds
and let's look at this.
So let's look at the magnitude of some
of these coupling constants is that are
called Jay.
Okay.
So in for adjacent positions in benzene
at six to eight hertz for next adjacent
positions is one to three hertz.
And for remote positions it's zero to
one hertz. So what does it look like?
It depends on,
yeah,
any thoughts?
The position of agents?
Yeah. It depends on position
obviously, but in what way?
Closer.
The closer they are,
the bigger the interaction.
Can I see the hands of
those who are surprised?
Okay.
Now let's look at these.
That's 1.85 this is 2.38
that's 3.07 on strums
and here are their coupling constants.
What do you think your theory, Derek,
it's not holding up right here.
It's exactly wrong. The close,
the closest ones have the smallest
splitting and the farthest ones have the
biggest splitting,
but we know that it shouldn't be
distance because we've just seen that at
averages to zero. So it must
be something else, okay?
It's not spatial proximity.
The through space interaction,
the dipoles average to zero on
tumbling. Okay? Now let's look it up.
Faa in here and look at those two protons,
top and bottom,
top right and bottom left. And look
at this particular molecular orbital,
which turns out to be homo minus three.
There are lots of others we could look at,
but this one is good to look
at for reasons. You'll see
now when this, when this,
uh, when there are two electrons that
are going to be in this orbital, right?
And when one of them is on this nucleus,
the one,
let's say the electron, remember it's
magnet too. When it's pointing up,
there's going to be in that orbital,
there's going to be one electron pointing
up, one electron pointing down. Okay?
So suppose the up one happens to be here,
then the down one can't be up there.
Only the down one.
The downwind can only be over here.
That is only the down electron
is available to be here.
It can't be the blue one when
the blue one is up there. Okay.
So the electrons provide a way to
communicate between the nuclei,
like suppose that that,
that this electron likes to
interact with that nucleus.
When that nucleus is up, let's say. Okay,
then in those particular molecules
where this nucleus is up,
this nucleus prefers to be down.
Okay.
And vice versa,
the nuclei would be lower in energy when
they're anti parallel than when they're
parallel. So it's as if the nuclei
were interacting with one another.
But in fact one is interacting with one
electron and the other is interacting
with the other electron, but the two
electrons are in the same orbital.
So they interact with each other.
One has to be up in the other down.
So it's this indirect
interaction through the bonds.
Now that has an interesting implication.
So in tumbling molecules,
nuclear spins,
communicate not through space,
but through paired
electrons on the nuclei.
Because if that other electron wasn't
right on the nuclei on the nucleus,
then as it orbits,
it'll cancel.
There's only one place that electron
can be where rotating the molecule won't
cause it to cancel.
What's that place
on the nucleus
when the electron is on the nucleus?
Tumbling won't average it,
right?
So what orbital does it have
to be in to be on the nucleus?
It has to be an SR,
but all right,
so it's only the s orbital electrons that
allow this communication to take place,
right?
So the j the magnitude depends on the s
orbital content of the various molecular
orbitals, not just the one I
showed, but others as well.
Now you weren't. Why is, why is this one,
the Auntie are trans.
Why is that bigger than this one?
Could it be that you have more
overlap here than you do here?
So the molecular orbital is better for
communicating between these two then for
communicating between these two.
So we have to decide which of these
orbital overlaps looks better to you.
The one on the right
or the one on the left.
If you had to guess which one is
better overlap, what would you guess
or you wouldn't guess.
Suppose I asked it on an exam and you
had a 50 50 chance of getting some credit
then, or maybe maybe it's 60
40 if your intuition is good,
which one is better overlap, this or
this, right or left. How many say right?
How many say left?
There are no lefts.
You think this one's better overlap?
Okay, well, let's see. Okay,
so which gives better overlap?
Now the way we can tell is to dissect it
into the atomic orbitals that are part
of those orbitals, right? So we
examined the overlap of the components.
So notice that this,
this one is a combination of a p orbital
here and an sp hybrid pointing that way.
This is a combination of a p orbital here
and an sp hybrid pointed that way and
corresponding over there and let's
take them apart so we can consider them
separately. Okay. So notice that
these are the same on both sides,
so we can forget that that's
going to be the same overlap.
But now the question is, which is
the better overlap? This or that?
Let's vote again. Partial credit
here. You chance to redeem yourself.
How many think this one is better overlap?
Notice that means that this,
if it's true,
that means this is better overlap if
this cause these are the same. Okay.
And how many think that's better overlap?
Okay.
Not many people think that and
for obvious reasons, right?
But let's dissect that a little more.
Okay?
So let's just look at this one
where the difference lies. Okay?
And this you notice as a combination of
these p orbitals and these s orbitals
and this is a combination of these
p orbitals and these s orbitals.
Everybody with me now let's see which,
which one?
Which ones have better overlap?
Okay, so this is good. SS overlap.
Okay.
And that one's bad.
Anti-Bonding and the P
orbitals good and bad.
Shall we vote again?
How many people think this one's better?
Good. Okay. You're thinking. Okay.
What haven't you thought about though?
This s can overlap with this p and this
asks can overlap with that p and the
same thing over there.
So here are two bad
overlaps between s and p.
Okay. And here are two good
So now the question is,
which is more important s with
p four s with s and p with p.
And if you had a photographic memory,
you would hark back to lecture 12 where
we talked about the overlap of carbon
hybrids and saw that curiously,
the s p overlap is bigger
than either s s or p p.
So in fact, this is the
dominant one, right?
And that one has better overlap.
Isn't that cute?
So the backside overlap is really counter
intuitive that this is better overlap
than that. They don't really doesn't
look like it in simple pictures.
I absolutely agree with you. Yeah. Okay.
And here's that thing from
lecture 12 last semester, right?
There's s with us at the distance of a
carbon carbon single double, triple bond.
Here's p with p and the sigma overlap.
And here's s with P,
right? So asks with p Wins.
Good.
Okay.
So now let's look at something else here.
This is a table that you can
find in the book and in many,
many books say this kind of thing,
but there's some errors here,
which is what I want to show you.
I mean overall it's worthwhile,
but there are a couple of areas.
It says identical hydrogens do not couple.
That is absolutely not true.
They do interact with one another,
but the coupling is invisible.
Okay,
so in fact the magnitude of the coupling
is not zero. It's 10 to 20 hertz.
Right?
But you can't see it because there's
no handle for the radio frequency.
The light can't cause a
transition between the peaks.
That would show that splitting and frame
26 that we won't get to until next time.
We'll show that. Okay, one
other one here. This one,
it says that the coupling is
six to eight and that's fine,
but it depends on this angle
because remember the overlap
of this bond with this
bond, which is what we just talked
about, is going to be bigger one.
It's anti than when it's that
one. That's a clips, right,
and something different.
When it's like this.
So it's going to depend on
this angle, right? And in fact,
it can be between two and 13 hertz,
depending on the con formation.
Now, of course, if it's
spinning around rapidly,
it'll average spinning
around the internal bond.
Okay. So it's, it's 13
when it's like that,
it's two hertz when they're perpendicular
and it's 11 hurts when their sin.
That's just like what we saw last time,
bigger like this than like this. Okay.
When it's, when they're Gauche, which
is one of the more likely ways to be,
then it's seven hertz,
which is that.
And that's also the average
of all these others. Okay.
And notice that this, if
you have a torsional angle
that's spit, if it's spinning,
then you average to six to eight,
right?
But if it's fixed in some molecule,
then you can measure the
angle by measuring j.
So that's another way to
get structure. Okay. Uh,
let's see what time we got here.
Uh, let me do this one last. Uh, no,
we'll do this next time.
Okay.